Andre we believe though we cannot yet
prove that our multiverse of universes
is 11 dimensional so think of this 11
dimensional arena and in this arena
there are bubbles bubbles that float and
the skin of the bubble represents an
entire universe so we're like flies
trapped on flypaper we're on the skin of
a bubble it's a three-dimensional bubble
the two-dimensional bubble is expanding
and that's called the Big Bang Theory
and sometimes these bubbles can bump
into each other sometimes they can split
apart and that we think is the Big Bang
so we even have a theory of the Big Bang
itself now you ask a question what about
the dimensions of each bubble well in
string theory which is what I do for a
living that's my day job in string
theory we can have bubbles of different
dimensions the highest dimension is 11
you cannot go beyond 11 because
universities become unstable beyond 11
if I write down the theory of a thirteen
fifteen dimensional universe it's
unstable and it collapses down to an 11
dimensional universe but within 11
dimensions you can have bubbles that are
three dimensional four dimensional five
dimensional these are membranes so for
short we call them brains so these
brains can exist in different dimensions
and let's say P represents the dimension
of each bubble so we call them P brains
so a pea brain is a universe in
different dimensions floating in a much
larger arena and this larger arena is
the the hyperspace that I talked about
originally also remember that each
bubble vibrates and each bubble
vibrating creates music the music of
these membranes is the subatomic
particles each subatomic particle
represents a note on a vibrating string
or viding membranes so believe it or not
we now have a candidate for the mind of
God that Albert Einstein wrote about for
the last thirty years of his life the
mind of God in this picture would be
cosmic music resonating throughout 11
dimensional hyperspace